pas les insectes petit rapide furtif est
carrément insupportable
vous êtes vous déjà demandé comment les
scientifiques faisait pour étudier le
mouvement si imprévisible des insectes
volants et bien figurez vous qu'une
équipe de chercheurs a réussi à
concevoir le premier robot volant
capable de suivre à la trace un insecte
en vol libre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la recherche s'est déjà penché sur
l'étude du vol des insectes d'ailleurs
souvenez vous on en avait parlé dans
l'épisode la chute de la mouche avouez
vous étiez resté complètement scotché
par cette étude mais celle dont nous
allons parler aujourd'hui risque de vous
laisser mouche mais bouge mais pour
percer les secrets du vol des insectes
et de leurs plus fine stratégie de
navigation des scientifiques de lorraine
spécialisé en robotique on imaginait le
premier système capable de capter le vol
totalement libre d'un insecte en créant
roulement de tambour un robot volant
enfin presque volant c'est plutôt un
robot capable de se déplacer dans les
airs grâce à un système de câble
et regardez un peu les images que ça
donne
[Musique]
l'insecte qui bat des ailes sur ces
images et un petit papillon de nuit
baptisé à gros titres il si l'on est
même si le robot est capable de suivre
un tas d'insectes différents ce petit
papillon est un cobaye de choix car il
possède un battement d'aile relativement
lent bien pratique à capter pour une
première expérience
bon alors faut pas me prendre pour un
jambon mans écoutez je le connais bien
ce petit gars là puisqu'ils les fichiers
est recherché pour destruction de
cultures légumières et pour suivre et
analyser le vol de notre petit papillon
délinquance est un vrai laboratoire
aérien qu'ils ont réussi à concevoir bon
regardez moi ces petits bijoux de
technologie la structure centrale en
cercle l'individu en vol un peu comme
une cage et une fois cerner la structure
se déplace pour suivre l'individu dans
ses moindres mouvements
les caméras s'activent pour tout filmé
et paf on le chope en flagrant délit
d'ailleurs observant de plus près notre
laboratoire volant qui accueille les
petites bêtes étudiés
sur la structure les câbles sont reliés
à quatre piliers sur lesquels sont fixés
des enrouleurs actionnées par des
moteurs permettant de les guider et tout
va se jouer ensuite au centre du
dispositif
les scientifiques place l'insecte ici
notre papillon préféré sur une petite
plateforme de décollage attention vous
êtes prêts le papillon est lâché dans la
zone de vol et dès qu'il se met à battre
des ailes le robot se déclenche et les
caméras embarquées se met à filmer le
robot se met alors à suivre l'insecte de
manière constante pour capter tous ses
mouvements et déplacements avec une
précision et une réactivité
extraordinaire sans pour autant le
perturber
peillon de labo sous l'oeil du rombo les
deux caméra embarquée permet d'obtenir
un modèle 3d articulé reproduisant le
mouvement détaillé de l'insecte c'est ce
qu'on observe juste ici en rose et c'est
ce modèle qui va permettre l'étude
approfondie du vol du papillon les
scientifiques envisagent par la suite
d'embarquer dans le dispositif un
stimulateur olfactif diffusant défier
robben sexuelle volatiles utilisé par
les femelles papillon et pourquoi et
bien pour pouvoir étudier la manière
dont l'insecte adapte son vol en période
de reproduction
ce qui pourrait permettre ensuite de
contrôler leur population pour limiter
les dégâts dans les cultures légumières
par exemple mais je vous jure c'est pas
moi vous ne m'aurez gérer
[Applaudissements]
comme quoi le battement d'aile d'un tout
petit papillon peut déclencher un
nouragues ans de découverte et
d'innovation ces annonces la caméra bon
alors qu'est ce qui te reste à faire don
à beaune toi